[Applaus] anni Hartmann und es geht hier
gleich weiter das ist eine schöne es geht
hier gleich weiter schlagaufschlag
und endlich habe ich jetzt mal die
Bühne für mich allein zum bin mal für mich
alleins dass ich da mal in Ruhe hier mal
ah na was Hase das ist sehr interessant euer
merkwürden aber was soll das jetzt machen
wir jetzt einen Jürgen von der Lippe look
like Contest oder versuche ich mich ihnen
schon optisch anzugleichen das ist auch
wieder recht naja also anzugleichen ich
würde eher sagen mann Wanzen aber da muss
man bisschen mehr kommen ist ganz schnell
noch viel Haupthafen verlieren oder
was ist der Mann Vorsicht ich würde
vorschlagen sie schlüpfen jetzt einfach mal
schnell also etwas unbequemeres und dann
dann gleich ja es ist ja schön immer beim
Kleinkunstpreis das ist immer so kurz nach
Fastnacht ist gell wo man dann alle immer
nur sagen es ist vorbei Fasching macht
Karneval die Trauer kommt immer Chemie wo
ist alles vorbei bei mir ist immer so also
bei mir beginnt am Arsch am Mittwoch
eigentlich immer die große Trauer weil
dann war die zwangsschunkel Gesellschaft
vorbei ist aber dann geht bei mir wo ich
herkommen in Bayern immer also dann gehen
die Tollitäten richtig mit sich durch am
politischen Aschermittwoch bevorzugen
natürlich in Niederbayern Oberbayern
Passau Vilshofen es ist äh es ist immer
schlimm der politische Aschermittwoch der CSU
da habe ich dieses Jahr als er wieder stattfand
erstmal so richtig gemerkt was ich in der
coronazeit so überhaupt nicht vermisst habe also
das war das war wirklich das war toll also wie
der Söder Auftrag an der Söder breitbeinig war gar
kein Ausdruck er kam an wie der Koloss von Rhodos
Herr Koloss von Rhodos in Bayern
am besten alles sie sind Bayern am
besten Bayern hat es besser essen der
Welt Bayern hat die beste Integration
der Welt Bayern hat die beste Luft und
Raumfahrttechnik der Welt Bavaria one
viele irgendwann in Bayern gesagt ja Bavaria
wann kommt sie wann ist bewerben egal Söder
hofft Söder hofft dass er die Grünen mit seiner
Rakete auf die hintere Seite des Mondes schießen
kann dann wird alles gut in seinem super Bayern
bestes Bayern er lange Zeit der beliebteste
Politiker außerhalb Bayerns er bestes Essen
beste Pflege beste Betreuung für die Senioren
gut Superman Söder der immer sogar eine Fakten
unterschlägt hat eins in seiner also bierseligen
jubelarie auch und den Tisch fallen lassen in
keinem anderen Bundesland sind prozentual so
viele Frauen im Alter von der Armut bedroht
wie in Bayern aber das hat der Söder gleich
das Jahr aber sie soll so weil bei uns in Bayern
da leben halt auch prozentual die meisten Frauen
wahrscheinlich ist daran auch der Linda
Finanzausgleich Schuld auf der dem alles
steht natürlich nicht schuld daran ist
das mittelalterliche Rollenverständnis
von Frauen Mann in Bayern Herd Mann
draußen am offenen Feuer Frau dann
irgendwann verlassen oder verwitwe zu Hause
weil der Mann draußen frühzeitig verbrannt
kein eigenes Einkommen Witwenrente reicht nicht
weil die CSU mit ihrem verstaubten Rollenbild auf
die Idee gekommen nie auf die Idee gekommen wäre
Frauen zu ermutigen für ein eigenes Einkommen zu
sorgen wodurch sie im Alter vielleicht ein eigenes
auskommen hätten haben können aber Selbstreflexion
war noch nie die Stärke der konservativen da gilt
immer nur von eigenen Fehlern ablenken indem er
gegen die anderen Holz Aschermittwoch ich habe
mitgezählt ich habe mir das angetan bei Phoenix
man muss auch dahin gehen wo es weh tut 105 Mal
kam von Söder nur nein weil nein nein nein nein
dann habe ich aufgehört mit zu zählen es war
wirklich immer gegen alles gegen alles was die
Grünen Vorhaben beim 97 mal Nein schiebt er dann
noch nach und gegen diese dagegen Partei gegen
diese verbotspartei gegen diese ewig ideologischen
nein sagen wir von der CSU ganz klar nein nein
und noch einmal nein
ich saß da Dings nein ich war wirklich gerade also
gerade ein Geschenk spielt die Kapelle in Passau
ein Prosit ein Prosit der Gemütlichkeit und Söder
schwingt die Maß die ersten Delegierten kotzen
schon unter die Tische und dann hebt er an und ich
will in Bayern keine Drogen ich will keine Drogen
auf der Straße die noch halbwegs bewegungsfähigen
im Saal posteten im glücksdrunken zu
weil schon auf dem Oktoberfest also der größten
drogenmesse der Welt hatte er sich damals schon
so in Rage geredet von wegen ja also Cannabis
freigeben nicht bei uns in Bayern in Bayern
und da ging der den Lauterbach so frontalern
also es ist unglaublich vor Corona zu warnen
und das Kissen zu erlauben da hat aber damals
schon Kurve Kalle sehr schlagfertig reagiert für
mich ist es völlig unglaublich vor Cannabis
zu machen und sich gleichzeitig ungeschützt
auf dem Oktoberfest ins Koma zu saufen es ist
wirklich immer nur immer nur drauf haben hallo
er möchte gern Kanzlerin passt einfach auf nein er
haut immer nur darauf dass kein Land der Welt ist
glücklich wann von der mit der Freigabe von Drogen
die Berliner Grünen wollen jetzt nicht nur die
Legalisierung von Cannabis sondern auch noch da
muss Kokain her und die Freigabe von Crystal Meth
da habe ich im Auto hat er so gesagt Crystal Meth
also was soll das jetzt sagen
rohes Schwein hat als neue Modedroge christliches
Mett gibt's künftig Hostien aus breit
finden wir dann in der Apotheke als
Ersatzdroge mit adonen ist das mit
der Hackfleischverordnung überhaupt vereinbar
oder ging es vielleicht um irgendeine Frauen im
ganzen Gesicht bei dieser Crystal Meth
vielleicht die Cousine von digidorbeer
ich habe nur auf den Satz gewartet dass
er irgendwann ankommt und sagt liebe
Freundinnen und Freunde das ist die Einstich
Droge für schwere Schweinshaxen das öffnet
die Tür für Cholesterin Missbrauch aller Art
aber das würden sie ihm auch noch durchgehen
lassen ich bin da also ich bin da jetzt
könnte also das ist unglaublich [Applaus]